a critical mind can only now be produced
in institutions other than those of
traditional education because although I
spent most of my life in universities
and in traditional educational
institutions I have to say that among
the changes of the last 20 years which
have been the most regressive has been
the remodeling of educational
institutions as Industries the
remodeling of educational institutions
as market oriented institutions that's
to say with internal profit fantasies
sort of profits that they make really
the key one of the key errors I think of
the last 20 years that was quite
different from deregulating markets is
that all social institutions have to be
restructured as markets in the and that
means an incredible hollowing out of
ethos I was lucky enough to go to a
traditional institution in which that
had not yet happened
a traditional Grammar School in Britain
followed by a traditional Oxford College
not from the background where I could my
family could afford that
but even if issues of access which have
gotten worse with the increasing
inequality of modern of recent times
were resolved what you would go to all
these institutions have been to some
extent deformed not to say that there
were no problems there were all kinds of
problems they weren't where they were a
Paik there were various difficulties of
many many kinds one didn't have any
nostalgic few of them but the key
element which is lost
and the key is is the idea of
institutions with their own ethos and
with having a non-market ethos and that
I think in education would include as in
a critical element the implication of
skeptical thinking the implication of a
disciplined sort of thinking in which
the fact that you want something our
hope for it is not by itself a reason
for thinking that it will and can happen